and I don't want my viewers to think
that people from the UK are all this
corny or weird so I got something that
you guys are all going to enjoy one of
my favorite videos straight out the UK
that preach actually showed me I'm a big
fan of and if in case you like uh
repetition and stuff like that I know
what you're talking about I know it's
what put that [ __ ] on
that's it Hey listen we recommend so I
just want my my audience to know people
from the UK are way cooler than this guy
okay and I'm gonna put you guys on some
of my favorite people out there yeah
okay one of my favorite radio stations
you know I mean there's people from the
UK right now watching who didn't even
know this video existed shame on you
shame on you for real for real everybody
in the UK should know that [ __ ] I'm so
surprised
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
20 years but this is 20 years ago I've
seen all right remember we don't do two
three summer Tunes out you lost for 20
years
[Music]
yo yo yo
back
up right now Mr
Jamaica
original Jungle is massive the original
down south jungle is there generally
leave you alongside Mr jump the world is
in trouble what's your name
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
happy birthday please
[Music]
[Music]
absolutely
[Applause]
today
[Music]
let's go okay boom watch that whole [ __ ]
out my mouth
[Music]
okay yeah anyways listen I love I love I
love England love London this dude
whatever man who cares and for those who
don't know go check out General leave
you all right y'all listen
the UK's got music okay and if you
aren't aware I've been a big fan of UK
music for a lot from garage to Hip Hop
to r b to grime
they got music out there okay so don't
let these kinds of people that we put
you on be the color for the you to see
the England for the first there's a lot
more out there so I just want to be able
to say anything you want to say it was
supposed to be so easy
yeah what's up have fun man